in this video we'll be talking about
fabis disease which is a losal storage
Disorder so obviously in any losal
storage disorder there is a
disregulation of losal function many of
these cases what happens is there are
several enzymes which are important for
losal functions are abrogated in this
example Alpha galactosidase a or Alpha
Gal A this particular enzyme is
nonfunctional and non-functionality of
these enzyme is due to a mutation in the
Gene that encodes this particular enzyme
so this particular enzyme breaks down a
particular lipid known as globo triy
ceramide so when this particular enzyme
is not active or Alpha Gal A is in an
inactive State due to the or not
produced due to the mutation in that
Gene it lead to an accumulation of this
globo triy ceramite this lipid
accumulation in different regions of the
body cause different problems in the
fabri disease so the classic fabis
disease starts from Early Childhood
whereas the non-classical one has a
delayed onset in this case there are
burning tingling and prickling sensation
in the lower extremities of the limb for
example in hands or example in the
legs and this kind of Sensations are
triggered by exercise there are also
neuropathic pain which is sometimes
quite
unbearable there are specific type of
rashes which develops in the lower
abdomen and the bathing trunk area this
is known as
angiokeratoma there could be intestinal
complications GI cramp uh frequent
bubble movement which might lead to also
constipation or even sometimes diarrhea
so overall there is gastrointestinal
complication which is very common to the
classic fabric disease
cardiovascular problems include
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy cardiac Aras
increased risk of stroke also there are
eye problems such as cornea vertic
celata then corneal opacities or even
conjunctival vessel
abnormalities renal problems are also
common in this disease sometimes there
are kidney issues and there are complete
kidney failures which requires
transplantation or hemodialysis so this
is a quick summary about all the
complications which are associated with
fabis
disease now Fab when when when genetics
is concerned fabis disease is an xlink
genetic disorder that means in the Next
Generation the male children has the
highest probability to get infected or
carry the disease females are generally
Max toax carriers it's very unlikely
that a female would be affected by fbis
disease but anyway when uh the carrier
female has at least one chromosome which
is okay so they have a less severe
mellowed down
symptoms then diagnosis of fabus disease
include detection of the enzyme activity
from the patient serum genetic testing
is the best option to deal with this
disease then to deal with problems of
Fage disease supportive treatments like
hemodialysis is important but enzyme
therapy especially synthetic version of
alpha Gal A and chaperon therapy is FDA
approved also pain associated with this
disease can be managed with painkillers
pacemakers can deal with cardiac
arhythmia and obviously hemodialysis is
important to deal with the kidney
problems so I hope this video was
informative if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe see you in next
video help our channel to grow and
support us via super thanks see you in
next
video